ركزوا معايا جدا يا اخوانا خلال شهر
اكتوبر اللي فات منظمات دوليه وحقوق زي
منظمه العفو الدوليه ومنظمه هيومان رايتس
واتش نشروا تقارير صادمه وثقوا فيها
استخدام الكيان المحتل لذخائر الفسفور
الابيض في عدوانه على قطاع غزه وجنوب
لبنان المستمر من اكثر من شهرين ولحد
اللحظه ومن ايام قليله وتحديدا في 11
ديسمبر الحالي نشرت صحيفه واشنطن بوست
الامريكيه تحقيق صحفي اثبتت فيه استخدام
جيش الاحتلال للفس الابيض في عملياته
العسكريه واكتشفوا كمان بعد تحليل شظايا
قذائف الفسفور الابيض انها صناعه امريكيه
يعني بعد ما بعض خبراء الاسلحه فحصوا
بقايا ثلاث قذائف مدفعيه من عيار 155 ملي
لقوا ان رموز الانتاج الموجود على القذائف
دي بتتطاهر
لما يجي يصنف الذخائر اللي بيتم تصنعها
محليا هناك الرموز اللي على بقايا القذائف
دي بتظهر انها صناعت في مستودعات الخيره
في ولايات لويزيانا واركن سس سنه 1989
و1992 وبحسب خبراء الاسلحه دول فاللون
الاخضر الفاتح وعلامات ثانيه زي دبليو بي
المطبوعه على بقايا القذائف بتظهر ان دي
قذائف فسفور ابيض طبعا بعد نشر تحقيق
واشنطن بوست طلع جون كيربي متحدث باسم
البيت الابيض قال اننا ه نشعر بالقلق من
استخدام اسرائيل للفسفور الابيض وهنبدا
نسال كده في الموضوع ومش عارف ايه الى اخر
هذا الهراب بس ايه هو الفسفور الابيض ده
الاول بصوا يا اخوانا لما بيتم اطلاق
قذيفه الفوسفور الابيض في الجو وبتوصل
للمنطقه المستهدفه بيتناسب الفوسفور
الابيض على شكل شرائط دي ماده شديده
الاشتعال بمجرد ما بتلمس الهواء بتتفاعل
مع الاكسجين اللي فيه بسرعه شديده وبتشتي
انتج عنها دخان ابيض كثيف بيغطي المنطقه
اللي بتنتشر فوقها والغرض الاساسي من
استخدام الفسفور الابيض هو خلق ستاير من
ال الخان الكثيف فوق ساحه المعركه بهدف
توفير غطاء واخفاء تحركات القوات وحجب
الرؤيه عن القوات الثانيه لكن مشكله
الفسفور الابيض انه ماده كيميائيه حارقه
بتسبب اضرار مميته لانه بعد ما الجسيمات
بتاعته بتسقط بيؤدي لنشوب حرائق كبيره ولو
وقع على اشخاص بيتسبب في حروق مميته
واستنشاق الدخان بتاعه بيتسبب في اضرار
كبيره في الجهاز التنفسي غير انه بيلوس
التربه والمسطحات المائيه وبياثر على
الحيوانات والاسماك كمان وبالتالي بيشكل
تهديد طويل المدى للبشر ولاي كائن حي
علشان كده استخدام الفسفور الابيض في
الاماكن المكتظه بالسكان محظور دوليا بسبب
اثاره القاتله على المدنيين واهم المنظمات
الدوليه حاليا بتتهم اسرائيل بارتكاب
جرائم حرب بسبب استخدام الفسفور الابيض ده
على غزه وقطاع غزه زي ما حضراتكم شايفين
عباره عن جيب ضيق طوله 41 م فقط وعرضه 10
م وبيعيش فوق المساحه الصغيره دي اكثر من
2 مليون نسمه وبالتالي فهو واحد من اكثر
الاماكن اكتظاظا بالسكان في العالم وده
معناه بالضروره ان الاضرار هتتضاجع
محرم زي ده لكن بجانب الاضرار الانيه اللي
بيسببها الفسفور الابيض في كارثه بيئيه
ثانيه متوقع حدوثها خلال الشتاء ده في غزه
بسببه وده بجانب الكوارث البيئيه الثانيه
المنتظره في القطاع واللي عاوزين نسلط
الضوء عليها النهارده فايه هي الكارثه
البيئيه اللي بدات تظهر في غزه حاليا ايه
علاقه تغير المناخ بالقصه دي وازاي اهل
غزه بيتم سحقهم بين مطرقه الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي وسندان ظاهره الاحتباس الحراري
وليه امراض معديه زي الكوليرا والتيفود
بدات تنتشر في القطاع كل ده واكثر هنعرفه
مع بعض في حلقه النهارده بس قبل ما ابدا
حابب اقول حاجه سريعه جدا من كام يوم حد
قال لي ما كفايه حلقات عن فلسطين بقى
عاوزين نتابع اللي بيحصل في العالم ومش هو
لوحده وانما في شويه تعليقات قليله بدات
تجي لنا بالشكل ده وردي عليه وعلى
التعليقات دي ان الكلام عن اهلنا واخواتنا
هو التزام اخلاقي ما فيش فيه نقاش التزام
باننا نوجه كل دعمنا ومجهودنا من بدايه
العدوان الاسرائيلي لصالح نصره فلسطين
ولحد ما الكيان المحتل يوقف عدوانه الغاشم
ده على اخواتنا واهلنا هناك وده هيستمر
حتى لو ما فيش غير واحد بس هو اللي بيتفرج
على الحلقات دي الموضوع مش مجرد تاديه
واجب او اثبات موقف بنعمله يا اخوانا
وبعدها هنقوم نشوف مصالحنا الثانيه الحسبه
بالنسبه لي انا شخصيا ولفريق المخبر
الاقتصادي مختلفه جدا يلا بينا نتكلم على
الكوارث البيئيه اللي مستنيه غزه او بدات
بوادرها تظهر فيها بالفعل انا اشرف
ابراهيم ده المخبل
[موسيقى]
الاقتصادي قبل ما نبدا انا وفريق المخبر
الاقتصادي هنكون حابين نشكر جدا شركه تلا
فيت راعي حلقتنا النهارده شركه تفيت اتاسس
سنه 2000 17 وهي شركه فيتناميه اسسها شاب
مصري مكافح اسمه ضياء الدين امين وبتصدر
لاسواق مصر والسعوديه والاردن وتركيا
وغيرها منتجات مختلفه زي البن والفلفل
وجوز الهند والقرفه والكاجو هتلاقوا تحت
الفيديو بيانات شركه تلفيت علشان لو انت
مستورد وحابب تتعامل معاهم وتستورد من
خلالهم المنتجات دي المنطقه العربيه من
اكثر مناطق العالم تعرضا لتاثيرات
المتسارعه والعنيفه لتغير المناخ درجات
الحراره في المنطقه العربيه يا اخوانا
بترتفع بمعدل اسرع بمرتين من باقي العالم
بسبب التغير المناخي باحثين من معهد ماكس
بلانك للكيمياء ومعهد كبرس في نيكوسيا
توصلوا لان المنطقه العربيه هتشهد ارتفاع
في درجات الحراره بنسبه تصل لاربع درجات
مئويه بحلول سنه 2050 مقارنه بمستويات
درجات الحراره قبل عصر الصناعه وده هياثر
على قابليه المعيشه والحياه في المنطقه
وممكن يؤدي لاجبار الناس على الهجره ده
معناه ان ظاه ظاهره الاحتباس الحراري
هتخلي الدول العربيه اللي عدد سكانها
قرابه ال 500 مليون نسمه تواجه تهديدات
مناخيه خطيره زي ارتفاع موجات الحر
وانخفاض هطول الامطار وموجات جفاف ما
كانتش موجوده قبل كده وعواصف رمليه كبيره
وفيضانات شديده وارتفاع منسوب مياه البحر
لو اتكلمنا عن اخر تهديد هو ارتفاع مستوى
مياه البحر هنلاقي ان 9% من السكان في
المنطقه العربيه بيعيشوا في مناطق ساحليه
على ارتفاعات لا تتجاوز خمسه امتار او اقل
من مستوى سطح البحر وبالتالي ارتفاع مستوى
البحر هيؤدى غمر مساحات من الاراضي
العربيه دي تحت الميه القطاع الزراعي في
الدول العربيه بيواجه برض تحدي خطير متمثل
في زياده حالات الجفاف وبالتالي ندره
المياه الصالحه للراي وفقا لبرنامج الامم
المتحده الانمائي فبحلول
2050 هتدي ندره المياه المرتبطه بالمناخ
لخسائر اقتصاديه بتعادل 14% من الناتج
المحلي الاجمالي للدول العربيه بالاضافه
لان 45% من اجمال المساحه الزراعيه في
الدول العربيه هتكون معرضه للملوحه
واستنزاف مغذيات التربه وانجراف وبالتالي
فممكن يحصل انخفاض في توافر المياه
الصالحه للراي ونقص في الانتاجيه الزراعيه
بنسبه 30% بحلول 2050 بعض تهديدات التغير
المناخي بدات تظهر في الدول العربيه لسه
في شهر سبتمبر اللي فات 2023 شايفين
العواصف غير المسبوقه اللي ضربه ليبيا
وتسببت في فيضان
ادت لسقوط الاف الضحايا وتدمير واسع
للبنيه التحتيه والمنازل ولسه الاف
الاشخاص في اداد المفقودين لحد اللحظه
علشان كده مؤتمر الامم المتحده المعني
بتغير المناخ والمعروف اختصارا بكب اللي
بدا يعقد كل سنه ابتداء من سنه
1995 والهدف منه وضع التزامات لها صفه
الالزام القانوني للدول للحد من انبعاثات
الغازات الدفيئه لتقليل اثار التغير
المناخي انعقد في الدول العربيه خمس مرات
لحد اللحظه دي دي اول مره في المغرب سنه
2001 وثاني مره في قطر في 2012 وثالث مره
في المغرب برده في 2016 ورابع مره في مصر
السنه اللي فاتت 2022 والسنه دي انعقد في
دبي في الامارات وخلص يوم 12 ديسمبر
الحالي بعد مفاوضات شرسه في كوب 28 على
مدار قرابه الاسبوعين نقدر نلاحظ الصراع
العنيف اللي كان بيدور في الكواليس بين
الدول المنتجه للنفط وعلى راسها المملكه
العربيه السعوديه من جهه وبين الدول
الغربيه من جهه ثانيه بسبب اصرار الغرب
على ادراج التخلص التدريجي من الوقود
الاحفوري في مسوده المؤتمر بشكل واضح
وصريح لدرجه ان مندوب الصين للمناخ شيه ت
شنهوا بيوصف كوب 28 بانه اصعب مؤتمر حضره
على الاطلاق يعني احنا في المنطقه العربيه
كل دولنا تقريبا هتتعرض للتهديدات اللي
وضحناها ولكن العواقب مش هتكون متساويه
الدول الاكثر سراء زي الدول الخليجيه مثلا
هتكون مجهزه بشكل افضل لتحمل الصدمات
المناخيه عن طريق اتخاذها لتدابير معينه
زي تحليه الميه والاستثمار في المشاريع
الزراعيه خارج منطقه الشرق الاوسط كمان
وطبعا قدرتها على استيراد المواد الغذائيه
واستثماراتها الضخمه في موارد الطاقه
النظيفه على عكس المناطق والبلدان الفقيره
اللي ما عندهاش موارد واللي بتفتكر
للقدرات اللي تخليها قادره تتكيف مع
التهديدات دي قدرات زي البنيه التحتيه
القويه والتكنولوجيا وراس المال البشري
والمادي وبالتالي البلدان دي هتكون معرضه
للتدمير والتهجير وعلى راس المناطق دي قطع
غزه طبعا الجيب الصغير اللي مساحته قد
مساحه حي مدينه نصر في القاهره وبيسك اكثر
من 2 مليون شخص واللي بيتعرض بقله شهرين
لعدوان مجرم من الكيان المحتل تسبب في
استشهاد قرابه 19000 شخص لحد وقت تصوير
الحلقه معظمهم الاطفال والنساء واصابه اكث
من 50,000 ثانيين وتسويه مساحات واسعه
بالارض وفوق ده كله للاسف قطاع غزه من بين
المناطق الاكثر تعرضا لتهديدات التغير
المناخي في المنطقه العربيه ومحله الدمار
الشامل اللي بيتعمد ه الكيان الزفر في
عدوانه على القطاع ففي كارثه بيئيه ومناخ
هتحصل هناك يعني عدوان عسكري مجرم مع ازمه
مناخ وشيك فا اللي بيحصل بالضبط هناك حتى
من قبل العدوان الاسرائيلي الحالي على
قطاع غزه المنظمات الدوليه كانت بتحذر طول
الوقت من ان اوضاع البنيه التحتيه والصرف
الصحي سيئه للغايه كان في نقص شديد في
الميه والطاقه والكهرباء والغذاء والخدمات
الصحيه طبعا بعد العدوان الاسرائيلي
المجرم الحالي ورمي الاف الاطنان من
القنابل تحول نص القطاع على الاقل لخراب
مكتظه بالسكان علشان بس حضراتكم تتصوروا
ازاي الكيان المحتل بيتعمل بغشوميه وبطش
غير مسبوقين مارك جلاسكو المستشار العسكري
لمنظمه باكس الهولنديه ومحلل استخبارات
رئيسي في البنتاجون قال لصحيفه نيويورك
تايمز ان القنابل اللي بيرميها جيش
الاحتلال على مساحه صغيره زي قطاع غزه
حجمها كبير جدا ونقدر نقارنها بالقنابل
اللي كانت بتترمي في حرب فيتنام او الحرب
العالميه الثانيه وقال ان حجم الدمار في
قطاع غزه بيفوق اي شيء هو شافه في حياته
المهنيه وده بسبب القنابل الكبيره اللي
الاحتلال بيرميها رغم ان الكيان المحتل
بيمتلك الاف القنابل الاصغر حجما من انتاج
الولايات المتحده برده واللي مصممه لتقليل
الاضرار كلام جلاسكو بياكد مسؤول عسكري
امريكي كبير لما قال لنيويورك تايمز ان
حوالي 90% من الذخائر اللي اسقطتها
اسرائيل على قطاع غزه في اول اسبوعين من
الحرب كانت عباره عن قنابل موجهه عبر
الاقمار الصناعيه بتزن ما بين 1000 ل 2000
رتل لو بصنا على وضع القطاع في ظل
التغيرات المناخيه اللي بدات تاثر بشكل
ملموس على المنطقه العربيه هنلاقي انه قبل
عمليه طوفان الاقصى بسنه ونص تقريبا
وتحديدا في شهر يونيو السنه اللي فاتت
2022 معهد دراسات الامن القومي في اسرائيل
والمعروف اختصارا باي ان اس اس بالتعاون
مع اللجنه الدوليه للصليب الاحمر عمل ورشه
عمل بعنوان قطاع غزه وازمه المناخ توصلوا
من خلالها الى ان القطاع بيواجه وضع
انساني كارثي بسبب الضعف الحاد تجاه ظاهره
الاحتباس الحراري وقابليته الشديده
للتاثير المناخ وده بيتمثل في الارتفاع
الحاد في درجات الحراره وارتفاع مستوى سطح
البحر وانخفاض هطول الامطار وظواهر مناخيه
متطرفه بتتسمع والشده زي موجات الحر
والفيضانات فمثلا دائره الارصاد الجويه
الاسرائيليه المعروفه اختصارا باي ام اس
طورت تنبؤات مناخيه لحد سنه 2100 مستنده
الى محطات قياس قريبه من قطاع غزه واللي
بتدي مؤشر لانماط الطقس ففضلا عن ارتفاع
متوسط درجه الحراره واحد ونص درجه مئويه
بحلول سنه 2050 وزياده وقت فصل الصيف على
حساب الشتاء فمتوقع يحصل انخفاض كبير في
متو وصط هطول الامطار في السهل الساحلي
الجنوبي اللي معظمه بيقع في قطاع غزه
وبالتالي ده هيقلل من امكانيه تجديد طبقه
المياه الجوفيه الساحليه بمياه الامطار
وبالتالي الزراعه هتتاثر سلبا في القطاع
في نفس الوقت الامطار هتكون اكثر شده
وبالتالي هتتسرب العواصف المطيره الشديده
في حدوث فيضانات زي الفيضانات اللي حصلت
من سنتين تقريبا في شهر يناير 2022 في غزه
وتسببت في تدمير مئات المنازل وتعطيل
انظمه الصرف الصحي متوقع برده انه يحصل
ارتفاع في مستوى سطح البحر في المنطقه من
07 من ل 1.8 متر بحلول سنه 2100 ارتفاع
مستوى سطح البحر بمقدار متر واحد بس هيؤدى
ازياده تغلغل مياه البحر في اليابسه
بمقدار نص كيل متر وده طبعا هيزود تسرب
مياه البحر المتوسط لطبقه المياه الجوفيه
في غزه وبالتالي التاثير على جوده المياه
الصالحه للشرب والزراعه انا ساكن على شبط
البحر ايه ت 69 سنه دورنا محلها هي هي
البحر اللي قدم علينا بقينا واحنا اولاد
صغار نلعب كوره ملعب كوره كان عندنا سنه
بعد سنه صار البحر يقرب علينا شوي شوي
احنا هالوقت بطلنا نشوف الرم بطلنا نش
البحر في الليل لما بيكبر احنا بن ضلنا
قاعدين بنامش في اللي بنخاف من
البحر طبعا الكيان المحتل هو المسؤول
الاول والاخير عن كل ده بسبب حصاره الخانق
على قطاع غزه من 16 سنه وبالتالي حوله لم
منطقه ضعيفه اقل استعدادا للتكيف مع
تهديدات التغير المناخي وبالتالي مقدار
تاثرها هيكون فوري وكارثي بخلاف الاراضي
المحتله الثانيه اللي بتواجه نفس
التهديدات ولكنها اقدر على مواجهه
التهديدات المناخيه والتعامل معاها بحكم
القدرات التكنولوجيه والماديه والبشريه
اللي بيمتلك ه الكيان المحتل هو طول
الامتار المتوقع انه يحصل في اي لحظه فوق
قطاع غزه هيكون مختلف عن اي امطار قبل كده
استخدام اسرا يل ذخائر الفسفور الابيض ادى
لتلوث الغلاف الجوي فوق القطاع وبالتالي
متوقع ان هو طول الامتار هيكون على شكل
امطار حمضيه ملوثه بالفسفور الابيض وفي ظل
النقص الشديد في مياه الشرب بيضطر سكان
غزه انهم يجمعوا مياه الامطار في اواني او
اغطيه بلاستيك وبعد كده يشربوها وبالتالي
الناس هتشرب مياه حمضيه ملوثه بالفسفور
الابيض وده بيشكل خطر كبير على صحتهم طيب
هل الناس عارفه ان الميه ملوثه ومع ذلك
بتشربها
وحتشبسوت غزه حاليا ما عندهمش مياه صالحه
للشرب وبيقوم موجه من العطش الشديد فبيض
طروا يشربوا مياه ملوثه بمياه البحر
والصرف الصحي والا هيموتوا من العطش قبل
العدوان الاسرائيلي ده كان في محطات تحليه
مياه كان القطاع معتمد عليها كمصدر لمياه
الشرب بعيدا عن المياه الجوفيه الملوثه
ولكن اسرائيل قطعت الكهربا عن غزه يوم 9
اكتوبر وبالتالي خرجت محطات تحليه المياه
عن الخدمه تقرير صادم لوكاله الامم
المتحده لاغاثه وتشغيل اللاجئين
الفلسطينيين المعروفه اختصارا بالاون
اصدرته يوم 17 اكتوبر اللي فات بيقول ان
الناس في قطاع غزه هيبدا يموتوا من العطش
بالفعل وان في مخاوف من الجفاف والامراض
المنقوله بالمياه بسبب انهيار خدمات
المياه والصرف الصحي واغلاق جميع محطات
تحليه الميه ومش محطات تحليه الميه هي بس
اللي توقفت عن العمل ولكن معاها جميع
محطات معالجه مياه الصرف الصحي اللي عددها
65 محطه بسبب منع اسرائيل دخول الوقود وده
تسبب في اطلاق اكث من 130,000 متر مكعب
يوميا من مياه الصرف الصحي غير المعالجه
في البحر المتوسط وده طبعا بيشكل خطر بيئي
جسين دوج وير مدير مرصد الصراع والبيئه
وهي هيئه بحثيه مستقله مقرها المملكه
المتحده بيقول ان الدمار اللي خلفته الحرب
الحاليه تسبب في ان كميات هائله من الحطام
والنفايات تسد المجاري وبالتالي ده هيتسبب
في ركود مياه الصرف الصحي وده هيشك مخاطر
صحيه وامراض معديه بسبب اختلاط مياه الصرف
الصحي بمياه الامطار وللاسف الشديد بدات
مياه الصرف الصحي تغمر شوارع غزه ومع وجود
جثث تحت الانقاض بدات تتحلل بالفعل فكل ده
هيؤدى انتشار الامراض المعديه علشان كده
المنظمات الصحيه كلها بتحذر من ازمه صحيه
كارثيه وشيكه في غزه وبالتالي زياده خطر
تفشي الامراض لجنه الانقاذ الدوليه
المعروفه اختصارا باي ار سي حذرت من
الانتشار الحتمي للامراض المنقوله من خلال
الميه زي الكوليرا والتيفو واللي بتسببها
مصادر الميه الملوثه ونقص خدمات الصرف
الصحي وان الظروف مهيئه دلوقتي لانتشار
الامراض المعديه والامراض المنقوله
بالمياه واللي بتاثر سلبا على الاطفال
وبتدي للوفاه منظمه الصحه العالميه برض
قالت ان نقص الوقود ادى لتعطل عمليه جمع
النفايات واغلاق محطات تحليه الميه وده
ادى لزياده كبيره في انتشار الالتهابات
البكتيريه زي الاسهال اللي اصاب اكثر من
33000 شخص من منتصف اكتوبر اللي فات
المنظمه اشارت لنقطه شديده الخطوره برض
وهي عدد النازحين اللي وصل لما يقرب من
واحد ونص مليون نازح في جميع انحاء غزه
وبالتالي المرافق الصحيه والملاجئ بقت
مكتظه بالسكان وده بيزود من خطر انتقال
الامراض المعديه بالاضافه لتعطل انشطه
التطعيم الروتينيه مع نقص الادويه اللازمه
لعلاج الامراض المعديه فكل ده هيزود من
خطر الانتشار السريع للامراض منظمه
اوكسفام وكالات الامم المتحده برض حذروا
من ان انهيار خدمات الميه والصرف الصحي
هيؤذن وبات من الكوليرا وغيرها من الامراض
المعديه القاتله لو ما تمش تسليم
المساعدات الانسانيه العاجله هتلاقوا تحت
الفيديو بيانات شركه تلفيت علشان لو انت
مستورد وحابب تتعامل معاهم وتستورد من
خلال المنتجات دي في النهايه ما فيش كلام
يقدر يوصف الكارثه اللي بتحصل في قطاع غزه
والاجرام اللي بيمارسه الكيان الصهيوني ضد
اهلنا هناك هنستمر في نقل اللي بيحصل هناك
على الارض للعالم كله لربما يكون لسه في
حد رشيد وبدعك للاستمرار في المقاطعه بغض
النظر عن تاثيرها على الشركات الداعمه
للكيان الصهيوني لكن يكفي بس نقدر نبص
لنفسنا في المرايه لان المقاطعه زي ما
وضحنا مرارا قبل كده هي سلوك اخلاقي في
المقام الاول بعد هيجي اي حاجه لازم دي
تكون نقطه الانطلاق بتاعتنا في اي شيء
متعلق بنصره اخواتنا في فلسطين انه التزام
اخلاقي بغض النظر عن النتائج اتمنى
السلامه لاهلنا في قطاع غزه احنا معاكم
وهنفضل نتكلم عنكم حتى لو العالم كله نسي
ورجع يعيش حياته
[موسيقى]
سلام
ا